what's up hey how's it going are you
free this weekend cuz I got no friends
but I got some great plans ahead for us
let's go
brunch okay first of all who doesn't
love a good meal with friends Plus
brunch means that you can eat breakfast
house still sleeping in Plus who doesn't
little bit mimosa am i right you know
what it's time to treat yourself go to
the mall and buy a nice outfit just for
you why because you deserve it
who's that sleepovers are just for kids
not me
grab a couple of your closest friends
and have a fun night inside look at how
much fun they're having
what oh look at them they look so cute I
love this thing even though I can't but
it doesn't matter because you can go out
and sing with other people who are
better than me and everybody wins
building a little bit adventurous this
weekend I can can be the perfect trip
for you especially after a long
stressful week think about all the
points of man photos that you can take
with nature so there we go all of our
plans for the weekend are set we're
gonna hang out we're gonna hang let's go
I'm dancing I'm dancing I'm dance I'll
pick you up see ya
[Music]